fighting eyes
first major tax hike since 1993
is what he got if you want to go on page
seven let's go through some of the
details the obvious is very very long
i'm not going to go through all of it
but i'll get pretty much the basic idea
of it
okay uh he is planning major tax act
since 1993 to help pay for the long-term
economic program designed as a follow-up
to his pandemic relief bill
unlike the 1.9 trillion autocova 19
stimulus act
the next inefficient initiative which is
expect to be even bigger won't rely just
on government debt as a funding source
preparations are being made for package
of measures that could
include an increase of both corporate
tax rate and individual tax rate
for high earners so rising raising the
corporate tax rate from
21 to 28. no yeah raising it from 21 to
pairing back tax preferences for
so-called pass-through businesses such
as limited liability companies or
partnerships pairing back tax oh my gosh
raising the income tax rate on
individuals earning more than four
hundred thousand dollar year income
expanding the estate tax reach and
higher capital gains tax rate for
individuals earning at least a million
dollars annually so
um matt why don't we go to your first
thoughts
thoughts uh you're penalizing their
earners you're penalizing the generators
i mean right here
higher capital gains tax rate for
individuals earning a lot of people that
purchase stocks and
buy businesses and uh uh things that uh
buy low sell high are our earners and
when you do well with that you start
making
listen if a common joe like me could
start making a million dollars
with no no no college degree just
learning a craft learning trade being
be mentored by upbd there's a lot of
other folks that's uh
in that in that range too as well buying
and selling buying selling so
again that's that's hurting other
investments in the business we've
invested into
uh other businesses by by making money
in one area and investing into other
businesses
so that's going to penalize those who
want to do but uh do i buy
and and hold uh versus buy uh sell and
invest into something else that's going
to affect that too as well
um again they're earning more money than
400 thousand dollars now by the way i
sound like a jerk when i say that don't
i
i sound like a joke yeah i i used to
make 20 000 a year
don't sound like a jerk and then and
then i'm like oh now that you're making
money
well yeah because i busted my tail for
it you know
nobody gave me anything i didn't have a
rich family to give me any money
and now that i've done what this country
allowed me to do and then i have these
type of policies now i got to look at
now pay more money i get to make more
money just to net the same
money just because i pay have to be
higher in income tax so that's that's my
initial feedback when it comes down
we're expecting this though
by the way here's a former marine eight
years you were in a marine how many
tours did you do two or three
i did uh two tours uh uh combat tours
where we where'd you go
so persian gulf war in an operation
restored somalia africa and then you
came back
as a single father yes okay single took
um you don't hear a single father often
it's your single mother but you don't
need a single father takes
responsibility and how what were you
doing to make money to support your kids
i got involved in the insurance industry
you know i got involved insurance
industry i was just a producer at
for 14 years high contract buying leads
and all this stuff and that was ultimate
burnout
uh because you know i realized wow if i
don't sell
um you know i don't make any money so i
mean great industry great business to be
part but as a single dad if i
just didn't feel like it or just had a
bad month i had a bad campaign
i'd be i'd be out of i'd be out of money
that's why you
teaching me how to scale you teach me
systems and processes and creating
company culture and creating a national
business and creating
you know uh duplication with the semi
with inside my business that's been
the saving grace for me and then my
income started to exponentially increase
so i did the right things we created
jobs and we had we've added jobs we just
hired actually today we have one of our
new guys in seven figure squad
starting today so we're creating i'm
doing what
i'm supposed to do as an entrepreneur
i'm not i'm not trying to compress i'm
actually
increasing our our payroll and getting
less people depending on other you know
church charity and government i'm
getting them
self-sustaining so matt growing up high
school what what did you guys live at in
chicago i lived in the berlin cicero's
stickney area went to morton high school
what what would you say that area is as
far as safety goes oh
middle to low middle to low give me an
idea like what are some things as a kid
this way coming out of high school the
reason why i joined sports i was which i
could say i had some very um
athletic aspirations you know i was
walking outside in the gang bangers
back in the years to have those long
socks that goes all the way up to your
knees well the gang bangers swinging it
with a lock at the bottom all the kids
are coming out of high school they're
swinging and just hitting hitting kids
no no police no narcs you know
everybody's kind it's kind of scary that
happened every day i said okay what
sport am i joining today
that was my type of neighborhood you
couldn't have a starter jacket remember
the starter jet yeah of course
of course people you can't have a
starter jack in your locker everybody's
getting their starter jackets
ripped up people's crazy starter jackets
i will never forget the starter jackets
hottest one was raiders everybody
everybody in l.a wanted the raider
starter jacket
and then in the 80s the the balls
and the bears though i mean don't forget
the bears as well correct correct
more so more so the bulls because
there's a long it was a longer run you
know
uh bears was it was just one year but
you know 86. and by the way the first
time i had a pair of jordans
was 42 years old when you gave me a pair
crazy right crazy when you think about
the reason why i'm saying this to you so
now watch this
matt how many people do you and sheena
support now the number
would i give in names how many people do
you support your family oh
kids in-laws parents your parents 10
plus 10 plus
so so that 10 plus support
is taking pressure off of who to go to
government
so you this is officially the government
of the supallas
that they take care of their family you
know the whole thing is about
i want to be socialistic with my family
meaning i want to be able to support the
people i love
but when it comes down down to business
i want to be capitalistic
let me let me choose my career right but
if i want to you know give
equally to all my kids let me do it
that's because i want to do it
don't force me to do it and he's
supporting his entire family and we want
to we want to hurt guys like him
i don't know about that but by the way
do you remember when we would debate
biden raising taxes and what would
people say
do you remember what people say that's
not true that's not true
or they could afford to pay it yeah no
they would say that's not true no he
never said he's going to raise taxes so
adam
tell us what you think about this
wonderful strategy that biden has great
segway
um shout out to to matt's apollo right
there for
doing what he i mean look you you kind
of touched on this that this is no
surprise because this is exactly what he
was running
on this is like as i'm reading these
notes i'm not like whoa where did that
come from
and and i'm not saying that i support
higher taxes like who the hell
wants to support higher taxes no the
problem was this
the problem was this obviously the
election was very close
and ultimately the election was decided
you know
november what happened you know uh what
what we got going on with no i just want
a spoon if you guys can grab me a spoon
um the election was closed but but just
to
revisit the past this is why that
freaking georgia senate race was so damn
important and this is why the
republicans
could not get out of their own damn way
and
look as someone who you know pretty
decent high earner i don't think we're
on the sao paulo level but
makes money definitely doesn't want
their taxes to go up
but this is why i was even saying look
i'm not i'm no
fan of trump i definitely i've been
vocal i'm voting for
biden i think trump is a fascist and i
don't want him around however
i if i were voting i would vote for at
least
one republican in the georgia senate
race
but the show that was the
republican party especially in georgia
trump kelly loffler uh
david perdue the bickering and the
infighting
led to what we have now if they had
their act together
and there wasn't a civil war in the
republican party we would have a
51 republican senate majority
and 49 in uh democrats and this wouldn't
be a freaking issue
and they wouldn't be passing 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus which i think
is obnoxious
a million a trillion dollars cool 1.5
cool whatever
but this is a little aggressive but this
is the ramifications of voting
but but as much as you say you have to
realize if you voted for biden
and he told you he's going to raise
taxes there were a lot of people that
said i don't know if he's going to raise
taxes
forget about the individual forget about
the personality
forget about who it is i almost think we
need to just have policies run for
office
not individuals run for office we have
policies run for office
here's policies on the left here's
policies on the right no color no
personality no temperament no twitter
here's policies what do you want to vote
for the next four years and you get to
vote
i think i think trump would add policies
say take trump out and just put his
policies you would have voted for 100 of
the time
let me say that one more time trump
without
the personality of trump if his policies
were put on the table and he had to
choose between the two
and there is no such thing as republican
party and democratic party
no such thing it's just policies and no
candidate who would you have voted for
well let me just say this as much
because we we've
we've addressed this allow me we've
addressed this before
take the emotions out of it purely right
right unfortunately that's not reality
but
so even if i were to say policy wise i
would i would vote for trump the whole
purpose of a podcast
the whole reason he got elected was
personality well okay so
again but go back to it because i don't
disagree with you what i'm saying to you
is if you take the personality out you
put policies out
which way would have maybe not a hundred
percent but your 50 50 split would you
have not been 60 40 to not raising taxes
i think without trump's i mean look tax
wise
look if taxes are the only freaking
issue on your mind
then yeah if you're a high earner of
course you're gonna vote but i'm talking
about trump but there's a lot of high
earners that both democrats put up for
different reasons though put all the
policies on the table
put all the policies on the table there
is no trump personality it's policy to
policy which way you're voting
policies there is no personnel if there
was no give me a percentage 55.45 on
these policies
as far as which direction if you voted
for the policies that biden had versus
trump's policies
the taxes are going to go into the rules
i'll tell you this there's a higher
likelihood i
i would trump would be more palatable
just based on his policies
based on his policies there's a higher
likelihood there's a point
that people would have voted for that
point i'm trying to make the point i'm
trying to make
is the election adds too much emotion
when there is personalities involved
and all i'm saying is maybe we have to
take a look at how we are voting moving
forward
maybe we have to take a look at how we
make a decision moving forward
maybe we have to take a part of the
personality out
and we don't get me wrong there needs to
be a lead dog there needs to be somebody
that's going to be leader to execute
certain things but
you know there's thank you by the way
there's also a challenge when
um there's also a challenge when
you know you have somebody that you can
have
one bad connection with him like you
look at trump and you say reminds me of
my father i'll never vote for him it's
not trump's fault you're just never
going to vote for him because he reminds
you of your father because
you know he was so strong like there's
no way in the god never ever will i vote
for him and overlook the policies yeah
and overlook the policies
because when you put the policy side by
side and i would debate my friends i
said tell me forget about
take the candidates out take the faces
out put the policies down
which way you're voting and i would mix
it up like you know i would put
right policies on the left side and rate
left policies on the right side
just i would say i said you realize you
just voted by the way
90 of the time they all voted for
conservative policies
and they didn't even know it well and
i'm not talking about people that are
republicans
i'm talking about reasonable like he's a
reasonable guy
if you sit down with him yes soyboy
mafia all that stuff and you know
you know he hates trump trump's a
fascist he just drops it out there like
it's a
proven fact yes he can say all the stuff
that he says yeah
but if we had the numbers neck and neck
right next to each other
you'd sit there and say damn never
thought about that before so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye